a coral reef taller than the empire  state building has been discovered  off the coast of australia scientists at  the schmidt ocean institute live  streamed an exploration of the new fine  in the great barrier reef  it's the first discovery of its kind in  more than 120 years they say it's more  than  1600 feet tall a team of scientists  found the reef last week while  conducting a year-long search of the  ocean  surrounding the country and what's  fascinating about this only five percent  of the world's oceans  have been explored i don't want to say  that it's amazing that they  found it yeah i know bigger than your  birthday party at the empire's table  again i didn't know it was there it's  130 feet below the surface  yes it's not that deep i mean yeah  there's a lot of cool  stuff in the water vlad there is and we  always talk about space exploration  i'm more interested in getting into a  submarine i got the nemo style  absolutely yeah